il a un ça va et il ya de l'action
nous sommes dans la classe de monsieur
eric un enseignant qui sort de
l'ordinaire
ici il n'ya pas de pin pad élèves non
plus assis en rang d'oignons attention
ils seront dévoilés à la nuit castrés
quand il l'a battu les la nuit monsieur
eric c'est un passionné de lecture
c'est aussi un oiseau rare sur les 27
personnes qui enseignent dans l'école
il n'y a que trois hommes en société
on cherche toujours les qu'il est le 50
50 la parité mais pourquoi ça devrait
être autrement dans une école primaire
au québec à peine 12% des enseignants du
nouveau primaires sont des hommes c'est
sûr que la proche d'un homme d'une femme
sera pas tout à fait la main qui plus tu
multiplies les types d'expériences que
des enfants peuvent faire dans un
parcours scolaire le mieux outillé vont
pas être en progression
le problème c'est qu'encore aujourd'hui
une minorité d'hommes choisissent
d'étudier l'enseignement primaire à
l'université
ici à l'université de montréal
actuellement il ya mille quarante et une
personnes qui étudient au baccalauréat
pour devenir enseignant primaire dont
seulement 85 garçons à l'université de
montréal c'est donc à peine 2 8 % des
étudiants qui sont des sommes
actuellement dans la plupart des
facultés d'éducation du québec
les to sont sensiblement les mêmes rien
donc pour augmenter le nombre d'hommes
dans les classes du primaire dans le
futur traditionnellement c'est un métier
qui fait mine est autant nos des
programmes pour valoriser le fait pour
des femmes d'aller vers des emplois non
traditionnels féminins autant nos potes
programmes prônent inverse pour
revaloriser la profession et recruter
davantage de personnel enseignant
la quête propose de bonifier le salaire
d'embauché des nouveaux enseignants de
8000 dollars mais pour eric il faut plus
que ça celui 1000 $ là j'aimerais
beaucoup plus la voir en ressources en
psychologie en orthophonie en
orthopédagogie que de le voir pour
bonifier mon salaire je vois comme un
8000 $ ça va changer la perception que
les gens ont du métier d'enseignant
ici dans cette place de l'univers
cité de montréal sur la cinquantaine de
jeunes qui étudie pour devenir titulaire
aux primaires il n'y a que quatre
garçons philippe affirme que c'est un
homme qui lui a donné le goût de
l'enseignement alors qu'il était en 6e
année j'ai vécu dans une famille qui
était séparé alors je voyais moins
souvent mon père c'est peut-être une
chose qui fait que cet enseignant un
lien n'est pas qu'un petit peu plus
important dans mon parcours scolaire à
l'école dans sa classe eric le constate
les gars ont besoin de modèles masculins
étaient d'un jeune garçon tu vois un
homme que tu respect qui va adorer
l'écriture et qui va est créé avec toi
ça peut juste envoyer le bon message sur
écoute je suis un peu comme toi et
j'adore écrire mais oui je pense à
l'année d'imposition légaux est ce qu'on
peut dire autre chose sur 36 josy
travail à la même école qui risque selon
elle il n'y a pas de doute les hommes
ont un rôle à jouer comme enseignant au
primaire
j'ai un garçon sic et aux primaires mais
présentement il n'ya pas eu encore
d'éducateurs masculin il n'y a pas eu
d'enseignants masculins mais la journée
ça va arriver
je le compare à ben ça va différents
j'ai comme le bout de voix pour gabriel
tout a changé depuis qu'il fréquente la
classe d'eric forcément comportement
était pas un héros qu'as tu lis juste
perso je prends exemple sur lui qui si
je prends l'exemple j'ai l'impression
que je monte plus haut c'est il m'a même
plus loin
de manière globale d'avoir des modèles
de lecture masculin puis des modèles de
réussite masculin ni un velcro le cac
roche le qui se développe beaucoup mieux
que certains jeunes
des jeunes garçons qui accroche à la
passion de monsieur eric et qui pourrait
un jour y enseigner à leur tour ici jean
philippe roy bien radio canada shannon
[Musique]